that what I'm trying to tell you yeah
you were the best player on your team is
that now we talking you could hit the
ball but I was fourth fifth hitter you
know what I mean
clean up yeah straight clean up on aisle
three come come get it sounds like
you're just an athlete yeah
any okay ping pong baseball football
basketball tennis swimming lacrosse
whatever you need me to play I'm gonna
go do it if it's some money online I'm
gonna go do it can you golf whatever you
need me to do okay
hockey whatever owners on the ring
whatever you need me to do it don't
matter got it trash can ball we whatever
you want trash can cook food cook food
that's something to do I bet I'll be A1
from day one